one of the questions that i get asked
all the time is about a bitcoin mortgage
hey i have a very large portion of my
net worth uh invested into
these assets but if i want to go get a
mortgage
they won't actually allow me to get the
mortgage um because they don't
underwrite these assets which is a huge
problem so
i'm very excited about this joseph how
are you excellent good good to be here
i'm very excited about this uh let's
start maybe first with how does a bank
underwrite a mortgage like if somebody
goes to apply for a mortgage
what assets do they determine i can
underwrite with and then why do they not
include some other assets i mean a lot
of it is really driven where mortgages
actually end up going so mortgages end
up going mostly to fannie and freddie
right government
so they have a process to really look at
a person's ability to pay they'll look
at what their income is and look at what
their assets are
they'll look at how much that person can
put down in an overall transaction and
what's happened is that over you know
the last sort of 60 70 years of
originating mortgages they've learned a
lot of things and they've learned that
it's really important for people to um
to to have the ability to pay and you
know over the course of you know on the
back of resource 2008 um the government
decided that you know they're going to
basically come up with these ratios
uh on income and they're going to want
to be able to prove it they're going to
want to make sure that that income is
continuous into the future um so assets
like bitcoin and crypto is really hard
for them to actually consider today um
but they're really looking at um at all
kinds of um you know just other assets
that are mainly mainly liquid that
they're really comfortable with
got it and so when you think about this
uh bitcoin and cryptocurrencies has
obviously become an asset that wasn't
here in 2008 and now is uh very very
popular is it just that they haven't
gotten comfortable yet or is it
something where uh they've identified
specific reasons why they don't want to
include it like hey we've done the work
but we don't want to include it yeah
yeah i mean i think that they're they
know that crypto's here right it's and
it's here to stay so i think that it's
very very clear that that's going to be
the case i mean statistically last year
one out of every eight first-time home
buyers in this country sold some crypto
for their real estate transactions so i
think it's undeniable that people have
crypto and it should be considered um i
think it's a matter of time i think that
it's probably going to take companies
like ours and probably others as well to
show them that this is a much bigger
piece of individual's wealth and that
they're going to have to start to think
about it so it really is just you need
the upstarts to kind of push innovation
and then eventually they realize hey
these people are making too much money
we got to get into that market right and
they try to come compete yeah and then
the reality is that this is wealth right
i mean i think that that that was sort
of like
phase one right you know is this gonna
be around yes it's gonna be around now
you know does this make a borrower
make their profile stronger right if
they have the ability to liquidate some
crypto to make mortgage payments then
you know that should be that should be a
consideration and today it's it's not
and i think that's one of the reasons
why we created our product is because we
saw that gap
when you think about the product that
you have uh is it just you just
underwrite bitcoin or cryptocurrencies
or you use it and holistically look at
crypto plus whatever other assets they
have yeah we have to look at the whole
the whole bar right i mean i think that
that's the element that a lot of people
assume well if i only if i have bitcoin
then a lender should be comfortable with
me just having that and the reality is
when you lend money to someone for 30
years
right you've got to really feel good
about that person you got to feel good
that they have the ability to pay you've
got to really look at all these other
elements and you know if you really just
sort of think about you know what is 30
years you know 30 years you go back to
you know
early 90s right you had a you had
inflation you had a savings and loans
crisis right you had long-term capital
failing in you know 98 you had
the com crisis you had the financial
crisis you had everything that's
happened in the last 10 years so it's a
long time to be able to underwrite a
consumer and you've got to feel good
about it and the way you do that is
looking at their assets you look at
their income you look at how they've
paid and ultimately
you know are they going to continue to
earn income to be able to pay pay your
loan um so yeah we look at we look at
everything when you think about real
estate i think a lot of people think
about real estate prices themselves and
there's obviously volatility in 2008
it's a great example where uh the prices
went down i remember i talked to kyle
bass who's one of the people who shorted
the the housing market and i asked him i
said how did you know to short it and he
said we were on a call with a bunch of
analysts and they said you know as real
estate prices go up you know two percent
a year or whatever he goes what happens
if they don't he goes uh that never
happens he goes what anybody started
paying more attention because they
literally were just so kind of ignorant
to the fact that prices may actually go
down and he realized the models would
all break and there'd be this huge
dislocation um
that's pretty well understood i think by
most people in the market now that hey
real estate prices go up and down and
that can cause problems uh but something
like bitcoin uh and even stocks uh as an
example in recent times they have a lot
of volatility so stocks are now down 20
or so uh bitcoin's down 50
how do you think about volatility in the
actual net worth or assets of the
borrower yeah i mean i think big
consideration when you do a mortgage is
you know one the ability for someone to
pay and i think the second component is
their willingness to pay so when you
actually structure a transaction like a
mortgage you're really looking at it
making sure does the consumer have
really enough skin in the game right do
they actually have a down payment what
is that down payment and is that enough
uh for them to continue to pay in
periods of volatility um it's funny that
you sort of say you know where real
estate prices have been because if you
look at the last sort of 60 years the
only time you really had a drawdown in
real estate prices you know with a trend
um was really through that financial
crisis period if you look at it from the
last 10 years right it's been nothing
but up and to the right
i think it's it's going to be
interesting to see at what clip but if
you look at the last 10 years it's
appreciated eight percent right last
year it was 20 you know different on
sort of geos um but you definitely have
to look at the the long-term the
long-term trend that you know probably
diversifying with real estate it's a
good thing right for from a wealth
creation yeah and when you're
underwriting these types of mortgages
are they're all residential or they can
be commercial as well so right now with
the loans that we're doing you know we
started off doing mainly investment
properties so
individuals that are buying
properties that are cash flowing that
are generating some type of income we
felt that that was a good place to start
because it allows us to really
underwrite the consumer underwrite the
transaction there's cash flow right from
a from an income perspective so it fits
uh better with our current model now you
know we want to start to originate at
some point you know primary homes but
we're really looking at it given you
know we've had thousands of people that
have applied for loans with us and
gotten pre-approvals and what do people
want do they want a mortgage or do they
want a property um so we're thinking
creatively around that structure
because a lot of the things of how the
existing mortgage market and the
regulation uh you know respa tilla
dodd-frank all these other things it
actually doesn't work well with crypto
today so so we're thinking a lot more
creatively around that and how does
geography play into this in the sense of
uh miami and kind of south florida's up
you know maybe 25 30 and other geos
might have only been up five or ten
percent over the last 12 months like do
you do geographic specific underwriting
or do you just look at the borrow itself
and and uh it's kind of a one size fits
all across the country yeah we're really
looking at it in three parts you know
one hits the borrower
right their assets their income their
ability to pay um two it's the real
estate right the property you know do we
like the property do we understand what
this property could rent for do we
understand um what it could sell for um
so that's an important consideration and
then we're also looking at um just how
the transaction's structured right from
a regulatory perspective right do we
feel good about it um is there an
existing framework um so yeah we really
look at at all components um
interestingly for us you know as a
company we've done over 100 million in
loans to mainly international customers
buying real estate here in the us and
those states are generally florida
california texas uh colorado arizona
right some of these other states um and
we're seeing very similar trends uh for
people that have um you know bitcoin and
crypto wealth that they want to buy in
those markets as well so it's telling me
that people want to live in desirable
sun-built regions as opposed to you know
some of these other suburbs yeah when
you think about uh the investment
properties themselves why would somebody
want to use their bitcoin as collateral
versus use other assets they have or
you know job and income or something
like that is it a necessity or is it
because there's some sort of advantage i
mean i think what we've found with the
consumers that we've done loans for
it's a desire but ultimately it's a
really strong desire that they want to
keep their their bitcoin right they
don't want to sell it um they don't want
to
have it trigger a taxable event for them
so for them it's a really important
consideration and i think that um the
other element is just because you can
sell it and have enough for a down
payment it doesn't necessarily mean
you're going to qualify for a mortgage
um so you need someone to understand
that that crypto wealth came from
somewhere you have to be able to run you
know kyc on the consumer you have to be
comfortable with the actual crypto
itself um so it's not something that you
know any type of lender can do and it's
one of the reasons why we came up with
this product because we felt we would we
would understand it from that first
principles perspective as opposed to
basically trying to uh make it fit into
something else so
when i look on the website uh for the
milo credit uh crypto mortgage uh there
are six things that you all kind of call
out i think is like the high level
benefits right so the first is you can
borrow up to five million dollars on a
30-year uh loan term you can finance up
to a hundred percent no money required
to qualify uh there's low rates five
point nine uh five percent to six point
nine five percent uh safe and trusted
custodian you don't have to sell your
crypto and then you accept uh bitcoin
eth and stable coins uh the one that
jumps out to me is finance up to a
hundred percent explain that in terms of
i think when most people hear they're
like
what's going on here how does that work
yeah that's that's that's a big one
yeah yeah we've given out let's see so
we've had over a thousand people that
have um applied for pre-approval letters
with us uh i would say probably about 40
of those have actually gotten a letter
um and a lot of those are actually
they're shopping right all across the
country trying to buy homes so um we
have a bunch of realtors calling us up
and saying you know what is what does
this mean because we've never heard of
this and this was really around trying
to provide that solution um to not sell
your crypto right if you're basically
going out and you have to sell for a
down payment
then right away that sort of removes a
lot of the uh benefits
um so we wanted to allow people to just
sort of pledge sort of that one-to-one
ratio you want to borrow a million
dollars
come to us you know post a million hours
of bitcoin we're still going to run
appraisals title insurance right we're
going to do all these things in behind
the scenes and make sure that we're
really comfortable with the transaction
um but you're not going to have to
liquidate it so so that's that's that's
a really big deal for a lot of consumers
and so it's not an under collateralized
loan it's basically one-to-one where
you've got to have the collateral
equivalent to the loan amount that you
want
here walk me through what is the logic
behind making it one to one versus over
collateralized or under collateralized
so
conceptually we could ask for less right
so if you think about it that if you
were to basically post a down payment
and you had bitcoin well how much would
you generally post well you'd probably
post
two to one three to one four to one
right in terms of you know from a
dollars back from from from a crypto
perspective so we wanted to think about
it in a transaction to say all right
this consumer is is not going to
basically be able to get a down payment
we're going to provide that down payment
for them we're going to give them the
mortgage and we're going to wrap it all
into one
so that ultimately means that yes we
could ask for
half of the loan amount but then that
would introduce potential volatility to
the consumer because of how volatile
crypto is arguably maybe not as volatile
as the stock market recently but um but
still volatile right so i think that
that was something really thinking about
it from a consumer's perspective where
if you get alone with me today right i
don't want to put you in a margin call
tomorrow right i want to give you enough
enough room and what we saw is that the
individuals that have that one-to-one
ratio a lot of them actually have a lot
more crypto as well um so it really
strengthens the bar profile so if you do
one-to-one talk to me about uh let's
just uh you have an example on the
website it says uh i want to borrow a
million dollars i put a million dollars
of bitcoin up as collateral um
bitcoin goes up
doubles right now my million dollars of
bitcoin's worth two million dollars what
happens to the loan what changes yeah so
so we looked at that that if the value
of the collateral goes up there's an
element where depending on the agreement
that you choose to have with us you can
either remove some of it or um it will
actually lower your rate at that point
in time if you choose to actually keep
that crypto with us
so it really allows you to have the
benefits of essentially making a
transaction uh less risky for us and
then the consumer's actually getting a
lower rate because of that
opposite example i put a million dollars
i borrow a million one to one bitcoin
drops 50 percent yeah what happens
nothing in that situation so the value
of bitcoin you wouldn't get a margin
call until it dropped 65 so that million
dollars turns into 350 000
they'd have to post more or they can
reduce the loan amount you know either
either one is okay and trying to get it
back into a a ratio that's acceptable
if it drops 90 percent
and i bought a house i obviously have
the house and i had my million dollars
worth of bitcoin now my million dollar
bitcoin is worth 100k yep i get margin
called i don't post any more collateral
do you just take my 100 000 worth of
bitcoin and i keep my house yeah as long
as you're continuing to make payments
right so that's that element where we
created this waterfall structure where
sort of the first thing that we're
looking at is the crypto right so if you
don't make payments then we have the
ability to liquidate some of it to make
sure that you're still making payments
obviously that's not designed to be a
repayment plan but it's it's really a
convenience um if you stop making that
payment and there's no more crypto for
us to essentially liquidate
and you continue to make your mortgage
payment there's no issues right you can
still you know own your house it's still
fine if you stop making payments then
we're going to go into sort of the old
way of basically having to go through a
foreclosure process
the question that i get a lot is from
individuals saying well
you have the house you've got all of
this sort of
home there why do you need so much
crypto and a lot of it is because people
don't understand that having an illiquid
asset like a house it takes a long time
to actually foreclose right on average
it can cost up to fifty thousand dollars
to foreclose on a property and can take
up to 12 months so during that period of
time for a lender it's actually a
liability because you have to pay taxes
you have to pay maintenance right you
have to carry all this other elements um
so
this transaction with having bitcoin and
having real estate from a lender's
perspective i think is it's a superior
mortgage product because um you have the
benefits of something liquid but then
you also have the benefits of something
tangible which is a real estate